[crowd yelling]
[chanting]
NARRATOR: Members of the
Youth International Party,
they call themselves,
converged on Chicago.
They said they were there
to protest the war, poverty,
racism and other social ills.
Some of them were
also determined
to provoke a
confrontation to draw
attention from the
convention to the streets.
Mayor Richard Daley vowed
to keep it peaceful,
even if it took force
to keep the peace.
He was backed by 12,000 police,
5,000 National Guardsmen,
7,500 regular army troops.
[crowd yelling]
Hundreds of marchers and dozens
of policemen were injured.
Restraint was absent
on both sides.
This was later
called a police riot.
During that frightful
week, the demonstrators
repeatedly tried to march on
the site of the convention,
the stockyards.
Repeatedly, they
were forced back.
But even inside the convention
hall the virus of violence
was pervasive.
Dan Rather and Walter
Cronkite for CBS News.
Take your hands off of me.
Unless you intend to arrest
me, don't push me, please.
[clapping]
[horn blows]